we started to think about enlightenment
we we try to divide it into two basic
ideas about enlightenment one is what I
usually refer to as the small
enlightenment experiences and these are
the kinds of experiences that people
have a number of times through their
life it may be kind of a sudden epiphany
about how to resolve some problem at
work or solve an issue with the
relationship some some issue you've been
working on it for a long time and you
suddenly figure it out you kind of
understand things in a different way for
the first time but that's the little II
experience and the Big E experiences are
usually those experiences that are kind
of are life changing their mind blowing
they change everything about the way you
think about the world about life about
death about spirituality whatever it is
it changes everything about who you are
for example one of the experiences that
people often have is a very profound
sense of an intensity of the experience
the experience is the most powerful
experience they have ever had and if
there's specific elements within it if
it's something that they've seen if it's
some vision of light or something like
that it's the most beautiful light that
they've ever seen it's the most
beautiful music they've ever seen it's
the most intense feeling of love that
they've ever seen so whatever it is it's
this very very powerfully intense
experience we can look at the areas of
the brain that help us to determine
which things in our lives are
particularly important are particularly
intense to us this usually occurs within
an area of our brain called the limbic
system which is the emotional areas of
our brain particularly areas such as the
amygdala and the hippocampus which light
up they go crazy when something really
important happens in our life the limbic
system also helps to write things into
our memory so when something happens in
our life you know thousands of things
happen to us every day we don't remember
most of them because they don't trigger
that kind of a response but if somebody
you know we get into a fight with
somebody will remember that for a while
because it was very emotional to us so
when people have these intense
enlightenment kinds of experiences not
only do they feel incredibly real at the
moment but they are remembered almost
for the entire lifetime of the person
that they keep coming back to that
experience and they always remember this
experience as being that life-changing
moment that from that point forward
everything was different
another core element of these
experiences for example is a feeling of
unity connectedness oneness so with the
person the people will often say I felt
connected with everything in the
universe I felt at one with God there's
an area of our brain a parietal lobe
which is in the back of our brain and
this normally takes all of our sensory
information and helps us to reconstruct
a sense of ourselves
and how that self relates to the world
in some kind of spatial way well we
found that this area of the brain in
particular starts to quiet down when
people have these profound experiences
of oneness or unity now this makes a lot
of sense if it's trying to create your
sense of self and your sense of space if
it starts to shut down well you lose
your sense of self you lose your sense
of space and and I suppose ultimately
one of the most important aspects of the
Enlightenment experience is its
permanence is that it rearranges the way
our brain works for the rest of our
lives so when people have that
experience and they suddenly now realize
what their beliefs are in spirituality
or their beliefs are about life or death
or whatever there's some incredible
change that occurs perhaps in many
different areas of our brain that really
rearranges the way the person thinks the
way they feel the way they behave in
life and one of the real key areas one
last area I'll mention at the moment is
one of the key areas that seems to be
involved in that is a very central
structure called the thalamus and this
is located deep inside the brain some
people think that the fact that the
thalamus is actually the seed of
consciousness and it actually takes a
lot of our sensory information and sends
it to the different parts of our brain
and it helps different areas of our
brain communicate with each other well
this is an area that seems to be
dramatically changed by these kinds of
practices and experiences so if you
think about it if the thalamus has
changed it's really changing a person's
overall perceptions of reality the way
they think about reality the way they
sense reality and ultimately the way
their brain interacts with that reality
these are not experiences that are
happening only to the mother teresa's of
the world and the Buddha's of the world
these are experiences that are happening
to everyone these are just regular
people these are people who go to church
they're people who are religious people
who are not religious people who are
agnostic people who had a drug-induced
experience people who were meditating
people who and my favorite some of them
were just people basically
walking down the street or driving their
car down the street and the experience
just hit them as a neuroscientist if you
look at everybody's brain we all have a
lot of the same basic structures in the
same basic ways we have our frontal
lobes and our temporal lobes in our
limbic system and even when you look at
brain scans usually we're not more than
five or ten percent different from each
other so we all have kind of the same
basic circuitry which makes me think
that the ability to have these kinds of
experiences is within all of us it's
just a matter of how one activates that
and whether one activates it through a
very traditional religious path or some
other more unusual path when you start
to think about how to induce these kinds
of experiences one of the things that to
me is very interesting is that we we
tend to look at kind of the more modern
technologies and there there's a device
called transmit transcranial magnetic
stimulation which sends magnetic waves
into different parts of the brain
there's been some work by other
investigators who have tried to see if
different electromagnetic waves into
areas like the temporal lobe along the
side of the brain help to induce these
kinds of experiences but for thousands
of years people have found ways of
inducing these experiences and you go
back you know into the shamanic
traditions and people using mushrooms
and peyote and ayahuasca and all these
other kind of pharmacological if you
will
substances and people have done various
physiological change have induced
various physiological changes in their
body by not eating for a period of time
not sleeping for a period of time going
into some kind of cave or doing some
sort of sleep deprivation process so or
sensory deprivation process and it's
interesting because in our kind of
Western modern way of thinking about
things we do tend to think about this as
you know you push a button or you know
that this is some sort of artificial
stimulation of these experiences for
example a shaman who takes some
mushrooms to get into a spiritual state
that shaman doesn't look at that whole
process as being artificial the that
shaman basically looks at it as this is
what I need to do to get my brain to
another level so that I can interact
with the spiritual world and part of the
way I always think about it as a guy who
wears glasses and doesn't see very well
when I wake up in the morning the word
a very blurry place I put my glasses on
in the world becomes clear so what if it
is that transcranial magnetic
stimulation or drugs or you know what or
meditation one of these are like
basically putting on glasses for your
brain to see the world in a clearer way
in a different way but that really was
always there in the first place so
there's some very interesting and
important epistemological questions
about the realness of these experiences
irrespective of how they actually wind
up getting started and how they become
induced in that particular individual
but it also raises another kind of
larger picture question and I challenge
my my own students a lot about this
which is where do all of our experiences
come from when you think about it from
the perspective of the human brain and
what I mean by that is is that if you
look at what's really going on and
what's going on whether or not I've got
a drug in my brain or not for neuron to
fire it all sodium and potassium ions
are crossing back and forth across the
membrane and it depolarizes the neuron
and fires
so there's out there there's these ions
that are moving across a membrane they
cause electrical activity which can be
measured that causes the neuron to turn
on its metabolic machinery so we can see
increases in metabolic activity and how
it's using energy and then there's the
release of all different kinds of
neurotransmitters in serotonin and in
dopamine the that move across this
little synaptic cleft and activate
another neuron so we're in all of this
does the thought occur you know where is
our thought where is our experience of
the world when we say we see something
we feel something we think something
where and all of that is that really
happening and so if I give person a drug
or if a person meditates or whatever
that they're doing you know how do i
altima back to what's going on in the
brain itself how reductionistic can we
ultimately be or is it possible that our
brain is merely just kind of receiving
all of this information and certainly
you know if you go through a kind of
Buddhist or Hindu perspective on a lot
of this consciousness is all around us
and our brain is more like a radio
receiver that taps into this universal
consciousness for a period of time while
we're here on earth
then goes back to that Universal
consciousness when we go away so we
don't know and and the bottom line is is
that neuroscience is going to have a lot
of difficulty ultimately being able to
isolate exactly where these experiences
are and how drugs or whatever it is that
a person is using or doing to and do
some kind of experience how that really
is having an effect and where those
experiences truly come from